guys Anna welcome back to the Leia hail
plan show so today we have a very
exciting guest a lot has been going on
over the last few weeks so I think it's
time that we uncover what has been
happening so joining me on the show
today is crypto investor founder of a
bit boy crypto which I think maybe gives
away YouTuber and the man that has been
leading the SBF investigation because it
seems like real investigators don't
really want to get involved so let's
bring Ben Armstrong on the show Ben
welcome how are you doing hey doing
pretty good
so good to have you I've been following
your entire search of Soundbar group
read your your investigation how you've
been uncovering it
um so I you went down to the Bahamas
I've been watching your streams firstly
are you still there and what was the
purpose of going
um no I'm not there we I had a team fly
down on
Friday so on Friday of last week a day
after Thanksgiving Black Friday we sent
three people down to kind of scout and
look around see if we could find Sam uh
secures location uh you know sort out
some other things of course we did some
uh tether and Del Tech Bank
investigation when we were down there
too
um we stayed until we were gonna fly out
Monday morning but then I heard back
from Sam at like two o'clock in the
morning on Monday and so we thought
maybe we could get an interview with
them but it ended up not happening so uh
we left on Monday night went to Miami
and of course I was at two different
conferences speaking uh last week
uh went very well there was some uh you
know excitement around that too if
people watched on Twitter but uh anyways
the idea is that uh we want to go down
there and get the truth because I got so
tired of hearing people say like oh he's
so protected down there or like oh
you're gonna get met with military force
no he doesn't I mean protection like
that's that's a myth now I knew that was
a myth he was walking around the complex
around the Albany a couple times
and so I just want to go ahead and
expose what was true and was not true
and I really wanted to get an interview
with him I really went down there hoping
he would uh you know he would tell a
story and he didn't want to do that so
he wants to take interviews and people
are going to throw him softballs not
from people who actually have hard
evidence of the things he's done uh
nobody will ask the tough questions that
I will ask and he knows that and I won't
let him squirm out of it either
yeah because I I was watching your
entire stream and the security they came
over
um I I just couldn't believe it I was
like wow how is this happening live
um so so what yeah why don't you think
he'll he'll he won't give you an
interview I mean I saw he gave um The
Blocking interview he unblocked you as
well is that right yeah he did yeah he
said that um what I've been told is he
was never gonna do the interview look I
think what you guys have to understand
is how personal things are between me
and Sam on this and I don't think
you know people really grasp how this
unfolded and how I got so I never had a
dollar on FTX I didn't lose any money on
FTX you know I actually I had a lot of
ftt and I sold it I told everybody in my
community to sell it two months ago so
on an ftt get out of those uh because we
started unraveling some of this stuff
slowly but surely
and so you know the first thing was is
that if you paid attention if you read
the screenshots you look at the
screenshots for my conversation with
them
uh some of them yeah I saw some of them
yeah okay so one of the key things in
there was where he gave me three points
a b and c c he told me that he likes
veggies on his pizza and he's a wimp and
doesn't like spicy food which I thought
was really funny uh but hey that was
basically him saying uh you know he
wants to get customer funds back but
point B was really pivotal because
there's a line in there that he says I
obviously disagree with your approach to
regulation
that tells you like he knows my approach
to regulation how's he know because we
sent him our bill like the the only time
that I've ever had even indirect
conversation with FTX
um was when we send them our bill uh to
get possible funding for it's like 3.7
million dollars to do this bill all the
way through now we have got the funding
for it so it will we're getting it
registered this week and it should be
public by the end of the month
and people understand like
why Sam was so opposed to what we were
doing
um that he actually sat on our bill for
three weeks and in that three weeks he
sat he tried to sabotage us he tried to
steal one of our major political backers
uh from one side of the aisle and then
that's the three-week period who
wouldn't who knew he was working with
the dccpa did anybody know that before
he came out and said that he was no I
don't think so no nobody knew that he
started that when they got our bill oh
wow because we've already got like
people are going to understand like How
Deeply entrenched in this we all are
like here in probably the next month or
two but the whole thing is
is that Sam got our bill and he panicked
he saw our backers he knew who our
backers were and when people find out
who our two main backers are they're
gonna be like oh that's a pretty big
deal and so he panicked and had to
somehow weasel his way in we were told
we were shooting once we got registered
to go in the Bozeman Bill and then all
of a sudden in this three week period
Everything Changes
um and that's because he went in and
tried to do his regulation so you know
that that's really where this started
between him and I
was was something very personal about
him trying to steal my politician and
trying to steal uh trying to sabotage
our bill and that's what started you
know unraveling this whole thing
so yeah okay so obviously there's that
personal kind of competition between the
the two types of bills that you have but
how did you start with uncovering that
FTX was insolvent and how did you know
to start telling people to pull their
money out well I would say this when we
don't build all their money out we did
not know that it was completely
insolvent like we we were shocked to
find out just how big the hole was uh
but the question is would we have ever
found out how big the hole was if CZ
doesn't go dump ftt yeah and I think
what people are going to realize is the
the person that blew the whistle on this
um and sent all this stuff to coindesk
and also to
um
CZ
that also is reaction to our bill
um we we believe I've almost got 100
confirmation of that I've got enough
confirmation of that to feel very
confident saying that
um is that that kind of changed
everything for them imagine your your
SPF and you've been working with Gary
gensor for six months trying to control
the crypto regulation space through the
SEC and then Here Comes this bill that's
basically taking the SEC out of power
when it comes to crypto that's very
concerning um and so he goes and gets
involved with CPA
and then someone else there at FTX sees
that and is like whoa this isn't the
direction I thought we were going this
isn't good for us in America and started
like sending this stuff out
um so you know uh what was what was the
original question could you ask yeah of
course yeah like how you started to okay
um realize what was going on yeah
exactly so so when I found out they were
doing a federal bit license that was
ultimately what they wanted to do nobody
believed me they're like haha go look at
September 27th uh my live stream I
talked all about it that morning uh
weeks before Sam even puts out his
political Manifesto
um that was you know really dumb but
once once he puts that out once I find
out what he's doing he's not a good
actor if this guy's trying to do a
federal bit license he's not a good
actor he is not good for the space and
so what happened is is we started like
really looking down some rabbit Trails
reaching out to people we started
working with a reporter from NBC and
once Sam put out his political Manifesto
and people realized that we were right
and we've been saying for three weeks uh
what he was trying to do and nobody else
knew all of his enemies were like oh
this guy actually knows some stuff we
should reach out to him so I just
started getting DM after DM because
people don't understand the full breadth
of how damaging what FTX was doing to
projects right now everybody's focused
on the retail investors losing money
which obviously the majority of the
space is retail investors so that would
be obvious why it would be kind of the
topic of the day but it's really their
incredibly sketchy business practices
criminal business practices against the
projects that really is the Crux of this
whole thing because without these
sketchy business practices they actually
don't have insolvency holds
um one of the things that they would do
we posted on our website people go to
bitwoodcrypto.com they can check out a
link at the top of the page the links to
a summary of a phone call we're going to
be actually releasing the real the
actual call later this week
of FTX I think it was uh FTX Japan
um admitting that they counterfeit coins
on their blockchain on their exchange
yeah yeah there's video and audio
evidence of this stuff so when people
find out like it really sets in what
they were doing the projects like people
would be really upset so we hook up with
this guy uh from new genesis a coin
nobody's ever heard of new coin because
FTX destroyed it never trade below 35
cents it's listed on liquid within 48
hours it's trading at a penny mm-hmm a
penny 35 cents to a penny that was
Almeida doing that they were dumping the
coin they were doing it through creating
counterfeit coins so they're inflating
the supply on the exchange and they were
just easily able to dump it all the way
down and so but the point is Hussein is
the CEO of uh of that company and he
messaged me and he started giving me all
this information saying I've been he was
like I've been waiting I've been waiting
for somebody and he started giving me
all this evidence and we started
reviewing it looking at the phone calls
the audio clips it's how he stumbled
across Dan Friedberg who is really the
architect of this entire thing
um also huge stake in Moonstone Bank as
well
um he had a lot to do with that deal
which people will find out you know
we're probably gonna do a video on it in
the next couple weeks uh but you know
it's through learning about this
counterfeiting that really showed us
the Fate Market we were looking at this
more as a story we weren't necessarily
looking at the story of insolvency we
were looking at as a story of a fake
Market with fake coins on it that don't
match your liquidity pools and you can
kind of do some you know some common
sense uh assumptions and some leaps and
judgment there and figure out how that
led to the larger and solvency old what
we didn't anticipate is we never ended
we thought we had a month work on the
story we didn't anticipate CZ coming out
a week later and obviously doing what he
did with ftt which makes total sense and
if you look if you look at what he said
when he first said he was going to dump
ftt
basically he took a shot at Sam for
getting behind closed doors with
regulators and trying to throw binance
under the bus yeah which once again fits
The Narrative of this all had to do with
regulation what my bill brought up for
them and things like that so so I'm very
close to the regulation team uh yeah
everything yeah no absolutely I think
yeah clearly it's all about it's all
about um the regulation here and I know
CZ wasn't happy about that at all that
was very obvious
um but what confuses me is you know this
the whole Space knows this everybody's
sort of looking at what happened and
thinking wow like eight billion dollars
gone people just lost their money money
created all the thin air but the
mainstream media are covering this like
he's this crypto genius this
entrepreneur that you know tried to save
Humanity but unfortunately you know he
didn't quite succeed but kudos to him
for working so hard I mean even the New
York Times Summit was an absolute joke
so I have to get your take why are they
putting him on a pedestal they're
putting Caroline on a pedestal it's so
odd why are they doing this uh the bank
uh Joe bingman Barbara freed Sam's
parents and Sam himself they're paying
these people they're paying them they've
they've Andrew Ross organ has been paid
off for a long time everybody in the
industry knows that who did you say
Andrew Sulkin yeah for sure he's been
he's being paid off oh yeah for sure he
he's uh you know an access journalist I
guess is what they call it he's a
pay-to-play journalist and if you look
back at some of the stuff that he said
about Sam in the past
um there was a big article not
necessarily about Sam even but if you
look back at a big article that was
written I believe Andrew Sorkin was the
was the author of it it was involving a
company called uh Arkham intelligence
okay all about ICP when ICP launched uh
all about how it was terrible and all
these people did all this bad stuff in
the background yada yada yada none of
the stuff in the article is true Sam
paid to do that because they wanted a
short ICP down they short ICP that
they listed synthetic Perpetual Futures
ICP four days
before it's spot traded anywhere they
allowed an artificial pump to run the
price up extremely high so it couldn't
be sustained so they could short it on
the back end and make a ton of money and
and this was this was a regular business
practice that uh you know that they
would do
and so that article just happened to
come out at the same time where they
were shorting it it's all it's all again
the propaganda from fgx and Alameda is
insane people can't grasp how far their
tentacles go with propaganda this is
very easily seen right
let me ask you this question if you saw
if you saw a post about Sam Bateman
freed let's say it was a New York Times
article about him
what percentage of the people in the
comments do you think are against Sam
and how many would you say are like
Kevin O'Leary in her for Sam
oh every everyone everyone in the
comments is against some like 100 all
the time they get ratioed it's amazing
to watch yeah
so so it's like everybody knows this is
common sense you know we've done polls
that showed 96 94 to 96 of people think
Sam needs to be finished in crypto never
come back needs to go to prison there's
a small percentage of people that don't
believe that right but it's interesting
if you go look at some posts or some
videos
that ratio will actually be out of whack
where it'll be like 70 30. like 30
people support him they're all about
comments they're propaganda comments
so when you think about 96 of people
agree that he's a bad person and needs
to be held accountable and then you look
over and you see the fact that that's
weird the New York Times Washington Post
Forbes Wall Street Journal they're all
in the four percent doesn't make any
sense and it really goes to carry on
this narrative mainstream media is debt
nobody trusts them at all they've gone
so extreme now to where their opinions
misaligned with 96 of the country so I
think it's exciting like I'm super
excited to see the death of mainstream
media and I actually think that this is
the beginning of that
oh I totally agree I think even um over
the last two years the flip-flopping on
you know the vaccines and the lockdowns
and all of that I think was just this
was uh I have not even the start of it
but was basically one of the things
which is going to be the death of
mainstream media um I know you speak I
know you speak a lot actually about um
what I'm about to ask you because I'm
excited to also speak with you do you
think that Stand By Me freed is some
kind of front or puppet for the global
Elites or the world economic Forum are
trying to push agendas through
controlling crypto because you know if
he was able to establish this regulatory
Monopoly then really it's like the world
economic Forum it's the SEC The
Establishment now have this major hold
on the entire industry
yeah I I think that was the plan but I I
think it's
I don't think it goes as deep as
everybody thinks that it does I think
everybody thinks like oh you know this
this must go up to the clintons you know
the clintons were you know in charges
you know how you know it wasn't the
clintons
because
it blew up overnight and it's a huge
failure and every politician who took
money has egg on their face
if the clintons were involved that would
have never happened so you know it's so
sloppy like what they've done here is so
incredibly sloppy that no I any plan
that can be set up in a way to where it
can be destroyed in one Fell Swoop those
are not the smartest people and the most
elite people in the world they make sure
their tracks are covered all the time
and the fact that there's so many Paper
Trails like here's another good example
of just how dumb they are
October 19th uh this year
Alameda created a Property Holdings
company in the Bahamas to embezzle money
into October 19th like we're doing three
weeks before full insolvency
you know they named it
Alameda Property Holdings like could you
could you maybe come up with a little
more inconspicuous name to where we see
the registration we know for sure that
it's you like if they were really good
they would have named it something
random they'd have like 20 different
real estate companies but they just
throw everything into that bucket
because they're not very experienced is
Joe bingman and it's Barbara freed
they're the ones who are behind this and
so it does certainly have tell a tale of
political corruption
um and and I want to say like I don't
think the politicians that were getting
the money they like getting the money
but they didn't know FTX was a scam they
thought they were like getting money
that was probably pretty safe uh you
you've heard some of these politicians
talk about we may have to give the money
back you never hear that kind of
conversation that's how much they want
to be separated from all this so Joe and
Barbara and Dan freeberg they've just
been really sloppy and I it's all going
to come back to haunt them
but Sam is the front man he is he is the
Patsy here he will be the one that goes
down
as crazy his parents are going to sell
him off the river which is not that's
why they're allowing him to get out and
speak and incriminate himself because
they know he's going to be the one that
ends up taking the fall for this
Caroline's already in New York that's
almost a sure sign that she's already
flipped she's working against Sam
because Sam's been taking shots at her
over the last week and this media tour
saying it was Alameda it wasn't it
wasn't us you know it was Alameda that's
a direct shot at Caroline
um so I believe she's flipped and you
know we'll get that evidence here you
know hopefully in the next month or so
uh but the whole thing is
this was certainly about political
contributions uh there was money
laundering in Ukraine that's a whole
other arm of this for sure all that's
true
but
it was done so sloppy that really I
think it ends with Freeburg and um you
know it ends with Friedberg and the uh
salmon uh Tim's parents
that's so interesting because I always
thought it went deeper because well help
me understand this how do you work so
closely with the SEC for six months to a
year whatever it was and they have no
idea that something is horribly wrong
like how does that happen
well
I guess yes he didn't investigate at all
you know I mean never asked to look at
their books they didn't have an
accountant so how could you look at
their books
like I don't understand isn't that a red
flag like the SEC working so closely I
mean does it doesn't that like imply
corruption or or is it just like
laziness well I think it's laziness and
it just means you trusting I think what
you look at here is you look at Gary
ginsler saw an opportunity
uh to be able to work with Sam to be
able to basically take a Stranglehold on
the industry of crypto
and so he wanted to work with him uh Sam
wanted to work with Gary obviously
because he wanted to push this Federal
bit license he wanted to crush all his
competition that's one thing that's very
consistent with Sam and FTX and Alameda
is a if you look at the coins they
attacked compared to the ones they
didn't the ones they didn't attack they
didn't see his threats any coin that
they attacked they saw it as a
competitor uh or or as a threat so I
think it's kind of like this
people see memes about me on the
internet right like there's a lot of
memes about me there's a lot of people
that don't like me for for whatever
reason I think I'm a nice guy but you
know a fun guy not a mushroom yes he
seemed more right to me I haven't had
any problems
so and we're building mineral live it's
one thing but however
on the flip side if someone comes in new
to crypto and they get on crypto Twitter
and they see these people saying
terrible things about me this is their
first impression of me as they come into
the space and I'm gonna have to work
really hard over a long period of time
to prove otherwise even though there's
no truth to whatever this person said
like they may have totally made
something up or uh you know just said
something about me personally whatever
and the new person comes in and they
believe it and they don't ever cross
check it well I think this is kind of
the opposite I think Sam came in with
those political ties he came in with a
lot of favor he was painted as the Boy
Wonder
and I think they just never thought they
had to investigate it I think they just
took everything in his word like we hear
good things he seems to be the adult in
the room he's the only person in crypto
wanting to hand us the keys to
decentralization uh to where you know
all decentralized transactions appear to
peer are illegal we need to work with
this guy this guy understands
traditional Finance uh I think that's
kind of what it was
that is so unbelievable and you you
mentioned that you think that Caroline's
turned against him his own parents are
willing to throw him onto the bus so How
likely do you think it is like um he
actually is uh he sees Justice or I
guess we see Justice uh 100 oh really
but what does that look like
well I think you know what's interesting
is I was talking about this on my show
this morning
is if you follow the politics of the
United States which I'm sure you do at
least loosely
uh over the last
four years the Democrats we only have
two parties here yay we wish we had more
y'all are lucky where you're at you get
more yeah
is it really we have but
well I'm actually based in Miami but
yeah I am from London uh England
actually and yeah we have a it's a
two-party system there are other parties
but they're not gonna be able to win
it's only conservative and labor two
party system sucks because it's all
about running for the next election and
there's never really any threat for
certain seats that lean heavily One Way
um and so I think that um
you know when it comes to what was I
lost my train of thought again I'm sorry
no you'll find you you were telling me I
asked you whether he's going to see
Justice what's that Justice gonna look
like
so so what's gonna happen
here if you look what the Democrats did
over the last four years Trump collusion
and then January 6 hearings that's all
we got for four years right well now the
Republicans are taking over what do you
think the house reform and oversight
committee is going to be looking at next
year
FTX money Trail for the political
contributions I believe that's what
we're going to see all next year so I
think it's it could actually be possible
that he doesn't get arrested until those
hearings are over
um that's not what I want we're actually
going down to protest uh outside of
government buildings in the Bahamas and
outside of uh I believe he's staying at
his mom's house in Old Spanish Bay
um there and it's on the listing for
properties they have it's another gated
community like the Albany so we're going
to be bringing people down there and uh
we're going to be protesting we were
told by people on the ground in the
Bahamas that if we put enough political
pressure on the government they will
arrest him so we're going to try to get
arrested in the Bahamas and that might
speed up a timeline to get them arrested
in the United States but ultimately
whether he's arrested now or whether
he's arrested after the uh the committee
hearings that I believe are going to
happen next year he's going to go to
prison I mean look how long it took
Elizabeth Holmes to go to prison you
know several years it takes several
years for this stuff to go through so I
just tell everybody to be patient like
there's there's too much evidence of raw
doing uh we we haven't I have enough
evidence alone to put him away for sure
no doubt about it so I think that this
can't be ignored unless they want to
fall in kind of that four percent trap
we were talking about uh talking about
earlier
yeah I think you're I think it's going
to take a lot of time um you know one
thing which really confuses me about SPF
is how he made his money
um so there's this whole he he says he
made nine billion dollars in three and a
half years or something by Arbitrage
trading Bitcoin so like what is there
any legitimate any legitimacy to this to
me this sounds completely impossible
where do you think he made his money
well I'll tell you what I've been told
which is he's very smart when it comes
to trading he's very smart and when it
comes to arbitraging he's very smart
he they made a lot of their money with
um with Alameda was something called the
kimchi premium and it's it's an
Arbitrage and I believe the South Korean
currency it's kind of a loophole it's
very small gains but you compound it and
it can be a lot of money that's really
where they kind of got started of course
James Street trading was a traditional
uh you know traditional Trading Company
that I think you worked with before
Alameda or there might be some
sloppiness maybe they're part of the
same company I'm not sure
um but he is very smart I've been told
he created an algorithm
back in 20
I think he created in 2017 if I remember
correctly he created an algorithm that
actually like predicted the top and
bottom of almost every single Bitcoin
move not over a cycle like over a day
and so he is very smart the problem was
this was never about money and this was
never about crypto
um this was about Sam being brainwashed
and doped up by his parents for years
and years and years and years
doing their bidding thinking that he was
doing the right thing right like it's
kind of like you know there's that
famous kind of uh situation where it's
like okay you have no money you're
homeless your child is dying
if you go in the store and do you rob
the pharmacy to get medicine to save
your child
it's one of those things that's like
well it's not right it's not legal
and wherever you fall on that side of
the argument kind of supposed to
determine what kind of person you are
not necessarily good or bad but yeah
your personality right well I think that
he thought all the stuff that they were
doing even though it was wrong and it
was criminal and it was fraudulent I
think he thought it was great or good I
think in his mind being able to control
the politics to be able to stop
pandemics we get into Greg Ellison wrote
about pandemics so you know Caroline's
that was a whole other story it was say
pandemics right we want to make sure we
fix climate change and we feed the
Homeless and we do all this greater good
stuff and how we get there does not
matter uh it's a moral you know
inconsequence so I think that's what
we're really looking at with Sam he
definitely did a lot of bad things but I
really do believe he was operating under
the the presuppositions his parents have
driven into his head since he was a kid
which are politics are the whole
family's in politics they're all doing
Pags the the brother the aunt the mom
the dad the Dad wrote legislation for
Elizabeth Warren you know so you start
to see the dirty political overlap here
with all this stuff but uh ultimately
you know I I do think that uh you know
he kind of thought I think he still
thinks on a sick level than what he was
doing was right
I'm very of the mindset that the the
ends never justify the mean so like if
you're you know if your goal is to make
the world a better place and uh you know
prevent fake pandemics you know that
it's okay to steal from everyone but
it's uh it's really bizarre but before
government real quick yeah if I could uh
yeah go for it interject I got some new
information last week while I was in
Miami
um it was pretty interesting I met with
someone because like who do they really
give money to you know who who did Sam
and invite him what's that President
Biden right exactly right a lot of
political donations but if you actually
look at the groups that they were giving
money to it's not that much no they're
being 10 billion contributions to
different places like if you've got 30
billion dollars like you know you could
give a good bit of that away but they
didn't there was a log Jam in the
philanthropy and what we've now learned
uh after uh I met with somebody last
week in Miami that showed me some
screenshots of a zoom call that she had
uh this person has a non-profit and went
to FTX to try to get funding for part of
their you know philanthropy uh
philanthropical efforts excuse me
and what happened was
she never talked to Sam
do you know who is in charge of
approving
the Charities parents Joe bankman she's
got a screenshot of her with him in a
meeting and basically what they what she
said is if it didn't have to do with
political they didn't really care and
they didn't really want to do anything
with it so Sam himself may not have even
known what his parents were approving
and not approving
um wow but yeah so that that's brand new
info
here first thank you for sharing that
with us that's crazy I just I can't
believe what kind of parents would throw
their son under a bus like that we'll
use their own child for you know
Financial political gains well they like
his brother better they like the brother
better they always have oh do they tell
me more I don't know enough about this
well you just dig into the relationship
between his brother uh Gabe his brother
Gabe's already been in politics has
already been doing
um had a kind of a similar not a trading
side obviously but I can't remember
exactly what business it was in but
basically business where they were
creating money for a pack to support uh
Democrats and um you know he's the older
brother you know there's always that
thing with the older younger brother and
um I think this was Sam big time to
shine and now he's embarrassed the
family and so they don't mind selling
him up the river so uh you know there's
there's a lot more with him and his
brother
um we're we're currently like working on
some stuff around kind of the family
relationships I don't want to give too
much away but
um you know there's definitely something
there yeah I need to check that out so
before people inside I do want to ask
you about freedom of speech I've um and
everything that's going on right now
with Elon Musk but I've seen you talk a
lot about
um Solana warning people about Solana so
Ben I need I need to know what's up like
what are we expecting with Solana you
sort of say you can't tell us but can
you can you give us something well I
mean basically
here's here's the situation a lot of
people are in right now
there's a lot of evidence out there
I know that there's hard evidence that
FTX was creating synthetic Celsius
tokens to dump the price of Celsius as
they were trying to make it insolvent so
they could buy it to fill their own
insolvency holds right I know there's
hard evidence of that I know who has it
but they're terrified and they won't
give it up there's a lot of thing is
very similar right
there is some hard evidence of what was
going on in the background when that
blockchain got paused uh I may have I
may have said it wrong on Twitter I was
saying like brute forcing transactions
through but the whole thing was is while
the salon of blockchain was down
basically Alameda was in the background
doing money laundering and
it's one of these things where the
person who has this information
I I can't share it on their behalf right
like they have to be the ones that come
out and share it but look at what
happens when you share information in
the space you know you become a huge
Target and people are scared people
really overestimate the the power that a
lot of these people have
um you know it's all smoking mirrors
right it's like we're just so used to
Rich and powerful people being able to
do what they want they're like oh if I
say something against them I'm going to
get in trouble I say stuff against them
all the time nothing happens to me
so that was one thing but there's
another part to it as well it's not just
what was going on because look
there's a lot of blockchain going down
and getting paused is a gigantic problem
no matter what what's going on in the
background yes if it was going down
naturally because it couldn't handle the
transaction load then that sucks it
doesn't even work
if it was being intentionally done
during a time for money laundering to go
on in the background then that also
sucks because I mean it's so centralized
somebody composite when they're ready to
do money laundering or
if there may be a combination of both
maybe it went down randomly and then
they use that time to do some money
laundering that's just one piece of this
though like ultimately that doesn't
really matter one way or the other
it's the way they did the VC lockups for
the tokens
basically this is where like step in and
serum and ftt itself where they really
come into play uh to where the actual
tokens on Solana
would be locked up right but they were
able to create synthetic versions of
those locked up tokens to use on other
platforms is leverage to be able to
create more value in let's say step in I
don't think Stephen's a bad project only
the people behind stepping are bad I
don't
I don't know the crossover between serum
and FTX so I'm not going to say the same
thing about them I'm just not sure but I
know a step in
I don't think they knew that basically
they were being used as a pump and dump
from FTX a lot of projects didn't
understand what was happening while it
was happening to them we even talked to
one project the guy was like yeah I'm
pretty sure they screwed us I can't
figure out how he sent he's an uh us the
evidence I sent it all over to Hussein
within an hour he came back it was like
oh yeah they actually stole 125 million
dollars
how they did it or whatever so when it
comes to these flywheel tokens and the
VC lockups that's really the thing that
over inflated the price of a lot of
these other coins they would just pump
on Pump Up Pump and then it was time to
get out of a project they would move on
to the next one and do it and you know
everybody well not everybody I guess but
the all-in podcast which moth is on a
lot people remember that clip of those
guys laughing at dumping salon on retail
investors you know and it just doesn't
sit well with people when you realize
this really was one gigantic VC pumping
them we all knew it though like
everybody knew Solana was being
artificially pumped right I mean you
knew that I did but actually not
everybody knew that by the way
um like I'm not gonna obviously name
names and stuff but like different
people that I that I was working with I
I have definitely said like oh I'm not
sure like we should do that um because
you know Salon or X Y and Z and they're
like nope I don't see any evidence of
this and I'm like ah I don't know about
that you have a blockchain that doesn't
even work why is it crushing why is it
crushing every other blockchain in terms
of gains and you've got the richest
like it was obvious you know like I said
it even on my show I used to say it I
used to say like because we we I think
we started talking about Solana really
is a good investment not Financial
advice
um when it was about two dollars and so
our audience got a really massive return
on salon and we had a big bag of salon
and we certainly liked watching it go up
for sure however
there came a point where I was like guys
this isn't natural you know like it's
obvious there's big VC money going into
this that's pumping it that's holding
back some other projects it's just like
it became an Open Secret in the industry
that everybody knew what was going on
but people couldn't necessarily pinpoint
exactly how they were doing it
um and you know that's one of the things
I told the Sam right before he blocked
me on Twitter uh before he unblocked me
this time but uh was you know everybody
knows that you ran the biggest you know
VC pump and dump on the planet
and it's funny isn't it like after
Solana topped out all of a sudden all of
these VC funds have like a new 300
million dollar blockchain fund to
incubate projects yeah they just stole
that money from retail investors yeah
it's just so crazy but I think I think
you hit the nail on the head when you
say
you could see something wasn't right but
it just wasn't obvious what it was to
pinpoint exactly where it had gone wrong
that was my issue when I'm when I'm
trying to explain to people that I'm
working with and I'm saying you know I
don't think we should we should do this
but they want to go ahead and do it um
you know because they like Solana
um let's move on a little bit because I
know it's been a crazy week Elon Musk is
now running Twitter I saw you posted a
few weeks ago um on Twitter you wrote
and I quote listen Kanye come to court
crypto and fight with me I assume this
is obviously to do with JP Morgan
closing his account so what's going on
with Kanye um and why are you supportive
of him
well things have changed a little bit
this week yeah I know he's going way too
far off the deep end I think yeah
certainly there's been points in his
career where you can look and think like
we thought he was crazy but maybe he was
crazy like a fox and knew what he was
doing uh-huh
and potentially
I would say this this may turn out to be
another one of those cases it's just
what he's doing is trying to isolate
himself and get people not to like him
maybe like maybe
I think so but he's not like you can't
say there's a bigger business goal here
because like nothing he said over the
last week really you know would indicate
people would want to give him money in
the future yeah sure so he went way too
far and actually like I I understood his
points where he was talking about
uh where he said that he loved Hitler he
also loved Mao Zedong he also loved
supermodels his point he was saying was
he loves everyone period whoever it is
he loves him and that's okay it comes
off bad on a sound bite but then later
on in the interview he does he gets into
some things that are a little where you
can't really mistake like the
anti-Semitism you know yeah it's there
for sure
um and so you can say on one hand that
you love Jews but on the other hand you
know you make some anti-semitic remarks
and not just like not barely
anti-semitic marks or like questionable
anti-semitic remarks like I posted a Joe
Bateman uh father's obituary on Twitter
and did you see that post no wow I
posted the obituary and all he said was
do what you want with this well in the
obituary I talked about how he was
Jewish
but it also talked about how he was in
the Masons and I was really referring to
just being in the Masons but everybody
attacked me thinking I was being
anti-semitic and I was like yeah
no like I was just saying like he's in
the Masons like you know there's a lot
of conspiracy theories around that so if
you're into those conspiracy theories
take this and run off with it like that
was something that I wish I would have
hated a little different maybe circled
the word Mason so people knew exactly
what I was referring to but that's like
people get crushed for comments like
that and it's like
I ended up having to remove the post
because it was just getting
misunderstood I I didn't like that
I think it's more important to be
understood correctly and so I just left
it alone but like that's not where you
look you say okay you can kind of go
extreme and you can be like oh man you
know that was not good
what Kanye said there's no second
guessing like nothing that he said in
that podcast regarding uh you know the
Jewish people was was good in my opinion
so I've supported I love Kanye like you
know I love them yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah no I love Kanye ever since Through
the Wire and uh when he first came out
and I've had you know most of his music
on on my phone and
um you know I certainly hope he bounces
back from this and and comes you know
back from the crazy Coop that he's
living right now which interestingly
enough you know he did that four hour
interview with Alex Jones yeah or I
think it was four hours I don't know how
it was I'm actually going in studio with
options on Monday oh no way that's
exciting what are you going to be
speaking about FTX FTX that's amazing
yeah I mean that that interview that he
did with Alex Jones was wild because
even Alex Jones the crazy Matt the
craziest of crazies even he was taken
aback um which is so so funny but you
know it's interesting because you know
Elon Musk is taking over Twitter this
week um
Kanye West gets banned the EUR talking
about potentially uh removing um Apple
from the from the App Store it's all
really stupid so I'm interested in your
take why do you think that the EU wants
to ban
um Twitter now that Elon Musk is in
charge
um it's kind of strange to me yeah well
I mean when you look at the tides
between the world economic forum and
their and their polls in American
politics like yeah they don't want free
speech you look at all the stuff that
the Democratic uh you know National
Committee or convention whatever it is
uh was doing the DNC was doing working
with Twitter
I mean guys it's easy to see what
happened with these elections like it's
really easy to see like they didn't have
to pull out votes from under the boxes
or under the tables like we saw with our
own eyes and they said didn't happen
like they didn't need to do that they
control Twitter they control Facebook
they control the narrative they shot
down negative stories surrounding Biden
and they popped up any stories that were
bad for Trump and I think that you know
I mean there was a line on the FTX uh
you know balance sheet that said like uh
Trump lose you know it was like hundreds
of millions of dollars dedicated to that
so we know all these people are working
together
um I you know it's weird to me how you
know I I try not to get too political I
try to stay politically agnostic because
I have backers on both sides for our
bill I think crypto is bipartisan
um for sure I don't want to turn into a
political issue but when you look at the
this is what I've told people people
know me they probably know I'm
conservative you know I mean I live in
Atlanta you know I grew up in in you
know rural Georgia and people would
probably guess what side I'm on right
but I try not to let that infiltrate too
much into my opinions on crypto and
stuff like that
um but it's just one of these things
where
you can't get dragged into one side or
the other on this because it's very very
very dangerous uh you know to go down
that road
however all that being said it's very
obvious to see that the Liberals are
much better at politics than the
Republicans like they're much better
they're much dirtier and they know how
to get stuff done and they're relentless
while the Republicans like they just
kind of like sometimes they take nice
guy approach and uh you know that that
doesn't really work in politics uh
behind the scenes so I think ultimately
you know when when it comes to
uh you know politics and crypto I'm
hoping the next year is going to go a
long ways towards fixing some of this
stuff because I do know that the
Democrats are going to be coming back to
crypto several Pro crypto Democrats
because they they understand like
they'll be isolating younger generation
if they don't come out on the right side
of this
um so yeah the stuff with Twitter is
crazy though look Elon Musk he's really
won me over on this I didn't like him
before I still never drive a Tesla you
can see me oh really yeah that's amazing
I I also would never drive a Tesla until
this week and I just like really
appreciate everything he's doing you
know I feel like I can speak and now I'm
like I just want to buy a Tesla to
support this man even though he doesn't
need my support I know I know
um just just finally quickly I want to
get your take on Central Bank digital
currencies I've heard you sort of sound
the alarm on them before and it kind of
falls into the whole thing with Kanye
because you know he had his um JP Morgan
Chase obviously they shut down his bank
account because of his anti-Semitism so
you are you concerned about Central Bank
digital currencies and how far away do
you think they are
yeah let's talk about cbdc's I want to
make one last point about Elon Musk real
quick though yeah Elon Musk has won at
this point
won this battle
a free speech because now with everyone
seeing how wonderful Twitter is with
free speech
even if he gets removed from the App
Store he creates his own phone his own
network immediately takes 20 of the
market with him and we all go there
official he he can't lose at this point
so I I think that's probably what he
went in and told Tim Cook and that's why
Tim Cook came out and we're like okay
whatever we won't remove it from the App
Store uh so Europe I don't know exactly
what's going to happen over there with
that uh but I would assume it would be
the same thing they who knows they may
not let him have a phone there so let's
talk cbdc's I
obviously cbdc's are bad obviously
they're coming like there's nothing we
can do to stop them the digital dollar
will be here in probably the next three
to four years
um well it's already here it's usdc usdc
will become the cbdc I believe if you go
back to October of 20 maybe September of
2020 uh Jerome Powell came out and said
that they were open to working with the
private sector uh to create a digital
dollar well that's Circle and coinbase
they've already created it it's already
there you know all they have to do is
basically you know I don't know if they
would create a closed permission version
of it or if they would just close and
permission it itself not 100 sure about
that we do know that they're already
working with circles already working
with uh the European Union as well uh
probably on their you know digital Euro
so they're they're coming it's a scary
proposition
and you know one of the reasons why
people are going to let them in so
quickly as convenience think about doing
your taxes right right now you got to go
to your CPA especially if you're in
crypto you got to spend so much money
dealing with this
however in the future when all of your
transactions are on a blockchain and the
government has every single transaction
that you've ever made uh in a year
there's nothing to sort they know how
much you owe you know so it the
convenience of that I think is going to
Usher it in I mean we know I've talked
to people that like literally would not
take Bitcoin from me like here I'll give
you some Bitcoin no no I'll stick with
my bank it's more convenient I'll leave
my bank you know it's the same kind of
thing we always trade rights for
convenience and that's probably what's
going to happen here but the cddc is
going to be really interesting because
it I believe we're going to look back
I'm sure you've seen the chart layoff
you know how long each currency has been
the world Reserve currency yeah it's
about 100 years somewhere thereabouts is
the average maybe it's like 108
something like that we're approaching
that for the United States for the US
dollar the next World Reserve currency
will be the US digital dollar and so
what that's going to do is it's going to
kick the can down the road on inflation
and money printing because immediately
overnight if the U.S digital dollar
becomes the world or becomes a world
Reserve currency the demand skyrockets
because it's so easy to get a digital
currency and hold it on a wallet
especially for people already in crypto
uh than it is to have a physical dollar
or a bank account or have to go do money
exchanging it'd be really interesting to
see the way that these digital these
cbdcs work within crypto exchanges like
they serve as stable coins right but
um you know it's different because it's
uncapped like right like tether right
now at 65 billion dollars worth of
tether grants
the digital dollar who knows how many
they'll they will have so it'd be
interesting to watch the fluctuations
there on on the value against Bitcoin
um but it is going to immediately shoot
up Supply and I I think what's going to
happen or shoot up demand excuse me
doesn't allow them to print more digital
money
and keep the Ponzi scheme going for
about 20 to uh 30 years and I think you
know it's a very important point to say
that I or you're a Bitcoin Maximus
I guess you could say so I mean I think
bitcoin's the best yeah I mean yeah yeah
well you know I understand the Bitcoin
maximalist way of thinking
the problem to me with the Bitcoin
maximal is they want it all tomorrow and
it's just not going to happen it's gonna
be it's a process it's going to take a
while I do believe eventually Bitcoin
does become the world Reserve currency
and it backs assets like gold backs
assets I think that's what we'll see or
gold did back assets I think that's the
future but we're a long ways away from
it it's not going to happen overnight
and I think that the cbdc eventually
it's going to fail as well and I believe
that when the cbdc fails that's when
Bitcoin gets ushered in his world
Reserve currency that's such an
interesting take I actually
um I haven't heard that before and I
actually do agree with you because I
think we're too early like they're not
gonna accept Bitcoin and I think they
need a cbdc desperately in order to
implement whatever kind of agenda they
want you know this 2030 you owe nothing
and be happy kind of agenda um it's not
until you're right that fails that
something else can be ushered in um but
yeah I mean I don't want to use one of
those I'm very anti-centralization I'm
very pro-decentralization
um very anti-government so this is going
to be yeah the next five years are going
to be really fascinating so just finally
I know you mentioned you're working on
um your own license please tell us more
about that and also where can people
keep up to date with everything that
you're working on right now yeah so we
can't make it public yet until we're
there's a process uh we had to get the
funding first funny funding's coming in
uh now we get to register this week uh
and then hopefully the next three to
four weeks we can make it public
whenever it officially it has to
officially get like a
a document number basically I forget
exactly what it's called I mean all this
politics stuff is new to me but what
what we're doing is like Sam wanted to
control crypto regulation obviously
that's what centralization is by nature
and he runs a centralized Exchange
so he wanted to craft the rules to
benefit him personally
I want to craft rules to benefit
decentralization and the philosophy
behind crypto
however I'm not smart enough to make
those rules I don't I don't know enough
about development or mining or uh you
know trading algorithms or what like I'm
not going to be the person that's going
to come in and create the regulation
there has to be a mechanism
to create smart crypto regulation and
that's really what we're working on
we're working on something
um you know that will have multiple
people on some kind of uh you know some
kind of committee basically that will
help determine the crypto regulation
going forward
represented heavily by crypto right we
wouldn't want Sam bingman freed helping
the decisions but it's probably like
Eric Voorhees yeah of course nobody's
gonna agree 100 on any one person I can
name you know six people I think would
be good uh you know Jesse Powell would
probably be pretty good is he Canadian
he may not even be American but I think
he's Canadian yeah yeah so but that's
the kind of people we want people that
like decentralization understand the
philosophy behind what we're doing not
just you know out to line their own
pockets and so that's what we're trying
to create is an alternative that will
get us to crypto regulation where all
the people that are making the decision
understand the technology and understand
what's at stake but yet we're not
willing to hand over the keys to the
kingdom on every single thing that's
what same wanted to do you want is a
decentralization take it here I'll give
it to you no no we want people who are
going to fight back I think that the
idea here is like let's say I ran an
exchange
and I didn't I believe I don't think kyc
is good right
personally and you know where I fall on
kyc I'm kind of neutral to it I
understand but also obviously I I
respect Financial privacy and and you
know sovereignty of your own money
however
kyc to me is not the worst thing in the
world depending on what it's for but
let's say I'm heavily against kyc and I
run Exchange
the government eventually is going to
back me in a corner and they're going to
make me do that kyc or else they're
going to close down my exchange that's
fine if you're going to back me in a
corner and force me to where I
absolutely have to give that thing up
for the greater good of the exchange and
what I'm doing in the crypto movement
like okay I can do that but the first
time they come knocking I'm not going to
show up at the door with the keys and
say here it is take it and that's what
Sam wanted to do so we we want to create
something that's going to create
pushback smart crypto regulation is
going to take power away from the people
that are currently trying to power grab
in crypto in regulation uh AKA Gary
ginsler because this guy does not have
crypto's best interests at heart uh you
know look at his ties to SPF alone
Ellison uh look at his ties to a lot of
different uh you know to Goldman Sachs
and you'll see this guy does not have
best interest in crypto at heart a lot
of your Bitcoin maximums might say that
he does because he doesn't like anything
but Bitcoin seems to be okay with
Bitcoin but what I would tell you is
just be very careful there too because
if you were allowed to only take over
the space
then who's to say the next thing they do
is not go after Bitcoin mining yeah you
know for the environment for the
environment yeah of course
yeah exactly
um I feel like they're already you know
trying to trying to do that um but for
me personally you know it doesn't matter
if somebody's protecting Bitcoin it's
are you protecting decentralization are
you protecting individual rights if
you're not then you know I don't trust
you so yeah no I think I think that's
really interesting I'm really excited to
see um you know what you're working on
progress I think we desperately need
some kind of healthy balance
um with good actors that actually care
for the industry and want to see it um
flourish with competition and everything
um so yeah I want to thank you so much
for coming on it's been such a pleasure
speaking with you and sharing all your
Insight thank you so much ben yeah
thanks for having me enjoyed it
absolutely and guys please don't forget
to hit the like button and subscribe so
you never miss a video and check out uh
bitboy across socials always lots to
learn from him until then we will see
you all next week bye bye